what's up pretty princess  yeah  you are so fluffy  you are so fluffy and pretty yes you are  you look all prim and proper  yeah  yeah  where did pookie go  there's cookie  hey  hi baby girl yeah  are you gonna go hang out with beijing  i'm gonna go hang out with beijing  you're just kind of looking at each  other like yeah  [Laughter]  look at him just chilling out  this is really good because  when we first got baby cookie yeah  uh beijing was not happy about it yeah  and she was always hissing at her and  beating up on her and stuff but it looks  like they've come to a  grudging acceptance now  they kind of like hang out too she still  hisses at her sometimes if she gets into  she tries to keep her alive yeah  but you know  oh goodness  look at her rolling  you're wrong